LYING, POMPOSITY, SMUGNESS, AND
GROUPTHINK.
SEAN HANNITY IS NEXT.
GOOD NIGHT.
IS THE MUSICAL >> Sean:
WELCOME TO "HANNITY" HERE WE'VE
BEGUN WITH THE FOX NEWS ALERT.
WE HAD BIG BREAKING NEWS ON
MULTIPLE FRONTS.
NOW SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM WILL
BE HERE WITH A HUGE ANNOUNCEMENT
TONIGHT THAT HE IS PLANNING TO
INTRODUCE AND MOTION IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE TO CONDEMN
THE SO-CALLED IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY IN THE HOUSE.
IT IS CORRUPT, IT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
I HAVE A VERY SPECIAL MESSAGE
FOR THE SENATOR MET ROMNEY
TONIGHT.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO WANT TO MISS
IT.
FIRST, THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
WE ARE GOING TO BREAK DOWN
TONIGHT, IN DETAIL, SOMETHING
CORRUPT AND DANGEROUS TO THIS
DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC THAT WE
LOVE.
WE WILL EXPOSE ON THIS PROGRAM
THE DEMOCRATIC TOP SECRET, THE
SOVIET STYLE IMPEACHMENT COUP
ATTEMPT, AND HOW IT IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED, UNCONSTITUTIONAL
ATTEMPT TO NULLIFY THE WILL OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE WHOLE PROCESS IS MORE
CORRUPT, LACKING ALL DUE
PROCESS, ALL CONSTITUTIONALITY
AND CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS.
IT IS BASED ON UTTER AND
COMPLETE NONSENSE, ZERO
VIOLATION OF ANY LAW BY THE
PRESIDENT, ALL THE PRESIDENT IS
REALLY GUILTY OF IS FAITHFULLY
EXECUTING THE LAWS OF THIS LAND
AND FULFILLING HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTIES.
WE WILL EXPLAIN AND EXPLORE THIS
PARTISAN DEMOCRATS ATTACHED FROM
ANY OBJECTIVE TRUTH.
TO BE A DEMOCRAT, YOU CAN
BELIEVE IN TRUTH, REASON, COMMON
SENSE.
THIS IS NOW A LAWLESS MOB.
NOTHING THAT WE ARE WITNESSING
IS DRIVEN BY FACTS, LOGIC, LAW,
CONSTITUTIONALITY, NO.
A PSYCHOTIC RAGE AND HATRED AT
ALL THINGS TRUMP, EVEN THE
MENTION OF HIS NAME.
THESE DEMOCRATS, THEIR ALLIES,
THE MEDIA MOB, THEY ARE
TRIGGERED BY THE MERE SOUND OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NAME.
THEY ARE SET OFTEN TRIGGERED BY
THE SIGHT OF A RED MAGGOT HAT ON
A 16-YEAR-OLD INNOCENT KID.
WHAT WE ARE LIVING THROUGH AND
WITNESSING IS A LEVEL OF MADNESS
AS A COUNTRY AND WE BETTER STOP
OR WE ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE A
COUNTRY.
IN THE LATEST EFFORT TO TAKE
THIS PRESIDENT DOWN, THE
COWARDLY AND CORRUPT ADAM SCHIFF
IS HOLDING SECRET HEARINGS,
SECRET MEETINGS, THAT RESULTS IN
SECRETS TRANSCRIPTS, ALL HIDDEN
FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS, THIS HAS
NEVER HAPPENED.
EVER.
IN ANY PREVIOUS IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDING.
NOW FORGET ANY AND ALL
CONSTITUTIONAL DUE PROCESS, THIS
IS BEYOND THE KANGAROO COURT.
I CAN AND BALLOONS BELIEVE IT'S
HAPPENING IN AMERICA.
AN ATTEMPTED POLITICAL COUP.
WHERE YOU HAVE THE CORRUPT,
COWARDLY, THE SHIFTY SCHIFF
MAKING ALL THE RULES AND HE
GOES.
NEW RULES.
RULES THAT WERE NEVER USED IN
THE PAST.
ADAM SCHIFF IS A HABITUAL LIAR.
WE KNOW THAT.
AND HIS WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL,
BRUTAL TAKEDOWN, IT IS QUOTE,
DESIGNED AND IMPLEMENTED, THE
INQUIRY IN A MANNER THAT
VIOLATES ON FAIRNESS,
CONSTITUTIONALITY, AND
CONSTITUTIONALLY MANDATED
PROCESS.
THEY HAVE DENIED THE PRESIDENT
THE RIGHT TO CROSS-EXAMINE
WITNESSES, TO CALL WITNESSES, TO
RECEIVE TRANSCRIPTS OF
TESTIMONY, TO HAVE ACCESS TO
EVIDENCE, TO HAVE COUNSEL
PRESENT, AND MANY OTHER BASIC
RIGHTS GUARANTEED TO ALL
AMERICANS.
GUARANTEED TO NIXON, GUARANTEED
TO BILL CLINTON.
ALL OF THIS VIOLATES THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE RULE OF LAW
AND EVERY PAST PRESIDENT.
KEEP IN MIND, IN THE 90s,
NEWT GINGRICH, WHO WILL JOIN US
TONIGHT, MODELED THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDING AGAINST BILL CLINTON
AFTER THE WAY THE DEMOCRATS DID
IT AGAINST RICHARD NIXON.
TOTALLY THE SAME WAY.
IT WAS A FULL VOTE IN THE HOUSE
THAT AUTHORIZED THE PROCEEDINGS.
THE SCOPE WAS DEFINED.
RULES AND PROCEDURES WERE
PUBLICLY ESTABLISHED.
WE GOT TO SEE IT.
SUBPOENA POWER GRANTED TO BOTH
PARTIES.
SUBPOENAS WERE SUBJECT TO A VOTE
OF THE FULL COMMITTEE.
THE PRESIDENT'S COUNCIL COULD
ATTEND ALL HEARINGS AND ALL
DEPOSITIONS BY THE PRESIDENT'S
COUNCIL HAD THE RIGHT TO PRESENT
EVIDENCE, OBJECT TO ANY EVIDENCE
ADMITTED, CROSS-EXAMINE
WITNESSES, AND RECOMMEND
WITNESSES.
NOW THOSE WITH BASIC RIGHTS
SUPPORT OF THE BILL CLINTON AND
RICHARD NIXON, NOT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IF YOU HAVE THE LINE, THE
COWARDLY, THE CORRUPT B6, WELL,
HE HAS SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT
IN MIND AND AT THIS HOUR THE
DEMOCRATS ILLEGITIMATE INQUIRY
IS BECOMING EVEN MORE SECRETIVE.
BELIEVE THIS OR NOT.
BREAKING TONIGHT, DEMOCRATS ARE
LITERALLY BLOCKING HOUSE
REPUBLICANS FROM EVEN HAVING A
COFFEE, COFFEE, OF THE
TRANSCRIPTS OF THE SECRET
HEARINGS THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO
WATCH.
REPUBLICANS WANTS TO SIMPLY READ
A TRANSCRIPT, THEY HAVE TO HAVE
A DEMOCRATIC MINDER, A STAFFER,
THEY BESET THEM.
WHEN TALKING ABOUT HEARINGS THAT
SHOULD BE HELD IN PUBLIC.
NOW HEARINGS THAT MY SOURCES, BY
THE WAY, ARE TELLING ME, ARE
BLOWING UP IN DEMOCRATS FACE.
THERE IS SO ONLY A FEW MONTHS
AGO THAT THEY DEMANDED THE FULL,
THE UNREDACTED MUELLER REPORT.
IT ALL NEEDS TO BE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE FOR ALL TO SEE.
WELL, THAT'S NOW CHANGED.
EVERYTHING NOW IS IN SECRET.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE JUST NEED TO SEE THE WORDS
OF THE REPORT.
WE NEED TO SEE THE WORK OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
REPUBLIC RECEIVES THE REPORT AND
HE SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO EDIT
OR RESTRICT OR SANITIZE.
>> THE MUELLER REPORT SHOULD
INDEED BE MADE PUBLIC.
WE NEED TO SEE EVERY BIT OF
THESE UNDERLYING DOCUMENTS AND
OF THE FULL MUELLER REPORT.
WE NEED EVERY WORD OF IT TO BE A
FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY.
>> Sean: A FUNCTIONING
DEMOCRACY.
OKAY.
NOW DEMOCRATS WON'T EVEN HOLD A
PUBLIC VOTE?
NOTHING IS TRANSPARENT.
KNOWN TRANSCRIPTS, NO HEARING,
NO NOTHING, KNOWN RIGHTS FOR THE
PRESIDENT, NO RIGHTS FOR
REPUBLICANS.
NO OUTRAGE FROM THE MEDIA MOB
OVER THE SECRECY AND HOW CORRUPT
THIS IMPEACHMENT COUP ATTEMPT
REALLY IS.
NONE WHATSOEVER.
THEY ARE NOTHING, THE MOB AND
THE MEDIA, BUT AN EXTENSION OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SO, WHAT DOES THE COWARDLY,
CORRUPT GOVERNMENT ADAM SCHIFF
HIDING?
HE'S HIDING A LOT.
SOURCES TELL ME THAT THE CORRUPT
SCHIFF STAR WITNESSES, THEY ARE
NOT COOPERATING WITH THIS PHONY
WITCH HUNT AND HIS NARRATIVE.
ONE PERSON BROUGHT IN AFTER
ANOTHER DEBUNKING THE BIG LIE
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP WITHHOLDING
FUNDS TO UKRAINE.
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT THESE
TRANSCRIPTS TO BECOME PUBLIC
BECAUSE IT WILL DESTROY THIS
PHONY, CORRUPT NARRATIVE.
INSTEAD, THEY WANT TO CONTROL
ALL OF THE INFORMATION SO THEY
CAN SELECTIVELY LEAK THAT ONE
SENTENCE THAT THEY THINK HELPS
THEM.
EDITORIALIZED TESTIMONIES TO WIN
PUBLIC SUPPORT AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
NOW, IF YOU SEE WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE, IT IS A CON JOB, IT IS RUN
BY THE BIGGEST SNAKE IN THE
WASHINGTON SWAMP, AND THAT SAYS
A LOT.
THAT'S ANOTHER BIG REASON FOR
THE SECRECY.
WHY?
THE COWARDLY, CORRUPT COTTAM
ADAM SCHIFF, HE DOESN'T WANT TOB
ADAM SCHIFF, HE DOESN'T WANT TOE
EXPOSED.
HE IS A FACT WITNESS IN THIS
CASE IN HIS OWN INQUIRY.
HE HAS NO BUSINESS --
THIS IS A TOTAL CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
REMEMBER, HIS OFFICE WAS IN
CONTACT WITH THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER, THOUGH HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER, BEFORE THEY EVER
FILED THE COMPLAINT THAT SPARKED
THE ENTIRE INQUIRY.
SCHIFF IS ON TAPE LYING ABOUT
THAT CONTACT IN A SEEDY
COMMUNICATION.
NOW, B6 DOESN'T WANT THIS
INDIVIDUAL TO TESTIFY.
WHY WOULD THAT BE?
BECAUSE THEN THE SO-CALLED
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER WOULD BE
FORCED TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH SCHIFF'S
OFFICE.
LIKE, WHEN DID YOU START
COMMUNICATIVE WITH SIXES HIS
OFFICE QUESTION WHY DID HE
ADVISE YOU TO GET ANY ATTORNEY?
DO THAT ATTORNEY WRITE ANY
PORTION OF THE COMPLAINT?
DID HE ADVISE YOU TO CONTACT THE
IG?
HOW DID YOU GET YOUR THIRD-PARTY
HEARSAY INFORMATION?
LET'S ALL REMEMBER ONE IMPORTANT
FACT.
THIS IS A SECRET INVESTIGATION
OVER A PUBLIC TRANSCRIPTS.
THE IRONY IS, WE DON'T NEED A
HEARSAY NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
TRUMP, MUCH TO THEIR SURPRISE,
RELEASED THE ENTIRE TRANSCRIPT.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
NO QUID PRO QUO, WHATSOEVER.
NOW WHERE IS THE CRIME HERE?
WHERE?
THE SAVER, I NEED A FAVOR.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH CREEPY
SLEEPY, CRAZY, UNCLE JOE BIDEN,
AND NOTHING TO DO WITH A 2020
ELECTIONS.
BIDEN WAS MENTIONED IN PASSING
LATER IN THE PHONE CALL BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT PARAGRAPHS THAT IS
SUPPOSEDLY SO PERTINENT, THE
PRESIDENT IS CLEARLY REFERRING
TO UKRAINIAN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE IN THE 2016
ELECTION.
LOOK AT WHAT POLITICAL OUTLINE,
JANUARY 11, 2017, NOT MEMBERS OF
THE VAST RIGHT-WING CONSPIRACY.
THE COUNTRY UKRAINE TRIED THEIR
BEST TO GET HILLARY CLINTON
ELECTED.
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
TRY TO HELP HILLARY CLINTON AND
UNDERMINED TRUMP BY PUBLICLY
QUESTIONING HIS FITNESS FOR
OFFICE.
THEY ALSO DISSEMINATED DOCUMENTS
IMPLICATING TOPIC TRUMP AIDEN
AND CORRUPTION AND SUGGESTED
THEY WERE INVESTIGATING THE
MATTER ONLY TO BACK AWAY AFTER
THE ELECTION AND THEY HELPED
CLINTON'S ALLIES RE-SURFACE
DAMAGING INFORMATION ON TRUMP
AND HIS ADVISORS.
THIS GETS EVEN BETTER.
THE REPORT GOES ON TO DETAIL A
CLEAR EXAMPLE OF COMING YES,
UKRAINIAN DNC COLLUSION AND
UKRAINIAN AMERICAN OPERATIVES
WHO WAS CONSULTING FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE,
MET WITH TOP OFFICIALS AND THE
UKRAINIAN EMBASSY IN WASHINGTON
IN AN EFFORT TO EXPOSE TIES
BETWEEN TRUMP, TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
PAUL MANAFORT, AND RUSSIA.
ACCORDING TO PEOPLE WITH DIRECT
KNOWLEDGE OF THE SITUATION.
NOW, HANG ON A SECOND.
WE JUST SPENT THREE YEARS, THE
MEDIA MOB, DEMOCRATS,
BREATHLESSLY REPORTING,
SCREAMING ABOUT ELECTION
INTERFERENCE AND THIS IS A BIG
DEAL AND WE CAN HAVE THIS IN THE
COUNTRY.
OKAY.
AND THEY SHOULD ALL BE THANKING
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR GETTING TO
THE BOTTOM OF THE DNC COLLUDING
WITH INTERFERENCE IN THE
EIGHTH 2016 ELECTIONS TO HELP
HILLARY.
BY THE WAY, IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER ONE MORE THING ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT'S PHONE CALL WITH
UKRAINE.
THE PRESIDENT SAID, I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO DO US A FAVOR.
OKAY.
THAT'S A STATEMENT PAIRED OKAY,
THERE WERE NO STRINGS ATTACHED.
ZERO QUID PRO QUO.
DOESN'T EXIST.
DURING THE CALL, THE GOVERNMENT
OF UKRAINE HAD NO IDEA THE U.S.
HAD TEMPORARILY DELAYED AID.
THEY STILL GOT THE AID.
PLUS, THE AIDE WAS NEVER
ATTACHED TO ANYTHING.
NOTHING.
AND THAT'S CLEAR IN THE
TRANSCRIPTS.
ESPECIALLY RELATED TO SLEEPY
CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE.
ESPECIALLY RELATED TO THE 2020
ELECTION.
AND LET'S BE CLEAR, DO US A
FAVOR.
WELL, WE ALL HAVE GO TO PHRASES.
YOU KNOW, I SAY, YOU KNOW, A
LOT.
THE PRESIDENT USES THEM ALL THE
TIME.
THE VERBAL ASIDE.
I COMPLETED MY POINT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SHE JUST DID ME A BEAUTIFUL
FAVOR TAKING IT A BEAUTIFUL
DISCOURSE HE PLANNED TO OPEN IN
THE GREAT STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA.
>> JARED WAS THERE, JASON WAS
THERE, I SAID FELLOWS, DO ME A
FAVOR.
>> YOU'RE DOING US A FAVOR.
IT'S A GREAT JOB YOU'RE DOING.
THEY CALLED US AND SAID COULD
YOU POSSIBLY MAKE IT ANOTHER
DAY?
WE DELAYED IT TOOK A WEEK SO WE
DID THEM A FAVOR BUT THEY ARE
DOING US A FAVOR BUT THEY ARE
BUYING A LOT OF AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS.
I SAID CAN YOU DO ME A FAVOR?
THE REMAINS OF THESE GREAT
FALLEN HEROES, CAN WE DO
SOMETHING?
HE AGREED TO IT IMMEDIATELY.
>> Sean: BIG LEAGUES FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
A RECAP AND TURNED TO ME AS A
REPAIR THAT'S THE PHRASE THE
PRESIDENT USES WE'VE IDENTIFIED,
HUNDREDS OF TIMES.
NO CONDITIONS WHATSOEVER.
YOU CAN LOOK AT THE TRANSCRIPT
OR THE PHONE CALL.
NO QUID PRO QUO.
LOOK AT THE TRANSCRIPT.
NO HIGH CRIMES, NO MISDEMEANOR,
NO BRIBERY.
NO TREASON.
THAT DOESN'T MATTER TO THE LEFT
AND THEIR FRIENDS IN THE MOB.
THEY ARE OBSESSED WITH
IMPEACHING THIS PRESIDENT EVER
SINCE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOT
THE WORLD IN 2016 AND I HOPE YOU
SHOCK THE WORLD AGAIN IN
2020.
IF THEY STARTED WITH THE WORD
IMPEACHMENT TWO DAYS AFTER
ELECTION DAY.
BY THE WAY, THE NINE MONTH
INVESTIGATION INTO TRUMP RUSSIA
COLLUSION, EMPTY.
THE FBI INVESTIGATION, NOTHING
COULD HOUSE UNTIL INVESTIGATION,
NO COLLISIONS.
BIPARTISAN SENATE INVESTIGATION,
22 MONTH MUELLER WITCH HUNT, NO
COLLUSION WHATSOEVER.
NOW WE HAVE THIS SECRET SOVIET
STYLE ATTEMPTED IMPEACHMENT COUP
THAT IS JUST THE LATEST,
PATHETIC ATTEMPT BY PEOPLE THAT
NEVER ACCEPTED THE RESULTS OF
THE 2016 ELECTION AND WANT TO
INFLUENCE THE NEXT ELECTION.
MEANWHILE, THERE IS EVIDENCE OF
QUID PRO QUO RIGHT IN PLAIN
SIGHT.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, EVERYTHING TO
DO WAS SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY JOE
AND HIS SON.
BY THE WAY, HE'S NOT A KID.
HE'S 49 YEARS OLD.
2015, 14, BITE AND PUT CHARGE OF
THE ADMINISTRATION UKRAINE
POLICY.
HIS SON HUNTER THEREAFTER GOT A
LUCRATIVE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS VERY SMALL HOLDINGS
CONTRACT TO BE ON THE BOARD OF
THIS MASSIVE UKRAINIAN OIL
ENERGY COMPANY OWNED BY A
UKRAINIAN OLIGARCH.
HUNTER WAS BEING PAID MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS PAID NO EXPERIENCE IN
UKRAINE CREATE ENERGY.
OIL.
GAS.
NONE.
THREE SMELL WASN'T PAYING FOR
HIS EXPERIENCE.
NOW, CAN YOU IMAGINE IF IT WAS
VICE PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HUNTER
WAS DON JR.?
WHAT YOU THINK THE MEDIA
OUTREACH WOULD BE?
IT WOULD LEAD THE NEWS CYCLE
FOREVER PAID ONCE AGAIN, WELL,
HERE YOU HAVE THE LAST, NOTHING
TO DO WITH TRUTH, LOGIC, BASIC
COMMON SENSE, OR FAIRNESS.
INSTEAD, THEY CAN'T HELP THAT
THEY WANT TO TAKE ON THIS
PRESIDENT THAT THEY HATE BUT
THAT THEY ARE TERRIFIED.
GUESS WHAT, THE ULTIMATE REVENGE
IS GOING TO BE YOU DECIDING TO
REELECT HIM.
THEIR FEARS ARE WARRANTED.
LET'S LOOK AT THE BRAND-NEW
POLLS.
PRESIDENT LEADS ALL OF HIS
DEMOCRATIC RIVALS AND I
HEAD-TO-HEAD MATCHUP.
IT EXCEPT FOR ELIZABETH WARREN.
I'M NOT SURE IF THAT'S GOING TO
BE THE CASE.
MUNIS FORECASTING A WHOPPING 351
ELECTORAL VOTE WIN FOR TRUMP.
GOOD NEWS?
IT WON'T MEAN ANYTHING IF THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ABLE TO WEAPONIZE
THE IMPEACHMENT PROCESS.
THIS IS THIS COUNTRY, AND ALL
HANDS ON DECK MOMENT.
IT'S BECAUSE DUE PROCESS, IN
TOTAL SECRECY, AND DEMOCRATS
REMOVING A SITTING PRESIDENT
FROM OFFICE OR ATTEMPTING, THIS
IS NOT HOW THIS GREAT REPUBLIC
OPERATES.
THIS IS CORRUPTION AT ITS
FINEST, IT IS CONSTITUTIONALLY
LACKING IN ALL VALIDITY.
AND I DON'T CARE IF YOU ARE A
LIBERAL, CONSERVATIVE, DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN.